welcome to this video playing gender
maybe I end up from from the Netherlands
um maybe there's something else want to
try the Sicilian con variation see what
he's doing with Quincy's with Knight c3
yeah I think here and like he has an
additional option of using this pin and
to try to misplace yeah some of some of
White's pieces um the night here
that he needs to retreat it I wonder hmm
maybe just castles I need to we treat
the bishop I wonder if I can take I can
play to to c5 or I should all I should
just put it back on his seven okay this
probably simplifies my decision you
don't want him to take f6
definitely okay so hmm if I go here it's
this helping yeah I guess so I think yes
Knight e5 I was thinking I guess this
should be okay I can always play the six
to the support this and in general it
seems that without f4 White's position
Lex likes some some sting how is he
going to put any pressure on me without
f4
okay so what's next if you place what
should you do a for maybe making sure b5
is not happening I probably will play b5
next move like Bishop e3 I can also
think about night h5 Oh interesting
this is possible of course covering c4
so what's what is this IDM Bishop e3 and
f4 may be okay won't be five I think
should be done anyway so Bishop d7 rook
c8 coming
pressurizing maybe the pawn on c2 so he
wants to control him he wants to control
g4 so Bishop e3 then f4 that's his idea
but I'm quick here I'm already
threatening before winning the e4 pawn
so just cover dad
just rook c8 I guess so I also have
Knight Queen a5 sometimes not at the
moment after Queen a5 he's got this
funny move from 95 okay so he's got a
form F 4 planned how to how to counter
that Knight d7 maybe so after F 4 I go a
5-1 possibility or defy of him the
classical counter strike in the center
rook da def 4 D 5 takes it's a bit a bit
too much
I can also try to to do this
not maybe Queen a8 coming to throw the
put to put more pressure to put more
pressure on on your form
Green a8 coming maybe you should try f5
here in this position so night g3 SS SS
point I guess
this is probably still advisable okay 93
after that interesting interesting
decision can even think about taking
here
I only have one minute so I should I
should be quick about that getting home
getting the central porn for the
exchange mm-hmm
maybe not the objectively best solution
but I needed to to play Wow interesting
the ship c6 maybe where's the queen
going to a seven to a 7 problem
so there's some way to exploit the honey
queen position
hmm yeah still I can go here okay
didn't I morning okay let's try to
activate the night as well
we should coming to Jack coming here
50 seconds not good not good
I just e6 hangs I just what the beep
what the heck
and it was a very good position at the
at the start but I am is plated
obviously check check
14 seconds unfortunately check 9 f3 yes
my Gras
offered Gras offered garage that's nice
have nice of him wow what the crazy game
yeah I spent as usual too much time
around here around yet of course
critical what feels like but like should
be ok but not not sure a computer gives
95 with a very clear edge already yeah
it's a combination I guess of this
weaknesses on the queenside and somewhat
somewhat some wood weak center this this
is what Bishop edge form as an
additional idea it's very good for black
but difficult so difficult to play okay
I needed to play a move and I decided to
give up the exchange which the computer
likes for Wyatt but from a human point
like is quite ok at least got some
chance especially to now is strong
yeah I was I really got myself into into
the trouble him Queen eight 793 yeah
it's it's it's a bit unfair to to
analyze this is part of the gameís it
was I mean I didn't have any choice and
she tried to use it and play play
quickly he fibers a bad decision but I
need to play some news I all I didn't
really appreciate night at five and
after that I'm probably toast you can
take the six yeah yeah I was I was
banking on and stuff like that maybe the
best kind of stuff but just got Queen g3
as well Jim you can probably take it and
here we should be two wins plus 11
that's quite much quite a lot okay so
there's everything everything threatened
just yeah it was clear that that I
should should be losing it should be to
again this also wins Queen night age six
is made made in some Jack this is not
that clear in fact check this
yeah the sad thing is ahead I don't even
have a check here so we just Stratton's
to to take everything was checking meet
me check I challenge him yeah okay I can
just take here there is no Ruka fade I
was just panicking with no time on the
clock
ruk f7 now is also may check but played
played this very very quickly which
still wins everything but somehow the
game continues now Luke f8 I don't know
I played played super quickly I mean
they all win check some over here
check with more time I probably take on
d4 but wanted to have it as simple as
simple as possible J he accepted a draw
in this dead position but okay would
have won on time okay Wow Becky game
thanks for watching